what's going on
what are you talking about
where is my freaking phone
you know what maybe it's in the ceiling
you know what maybe you're in the
ceiling
okay
i don't trust you phyllis
and
i have a mission to accomplish make sure
this party gets rolling and i will be
back shortly ew
where are you going you want me to come
with oh
he says listen i forgot to tell you the
plan for this saturday you me bar beers
buzzed
wings shots drunk waitresses hot
football cornell hofstra slaughter
then quick nap at my place and we hit
the t sound no
i don't want to do any of that
duh
which is why i was joking about doing it
just stop stop
just stop doing it you're going to drive
me crazy
fine i'll just go sit at my desk and be
quiet
sorry i annoyed you with my friendship
[Music]
excuse me
and i'm also sorry
that a lot of people here for some
reason think it's funny to steal
someone's personal property and hide it
from them
here's a little news flash it's not
funny
in fact it's pretty freaking unfunny
that was an overreaction
gonna hit the break room does anybody
want anything
ma'am you good
yeah sure okay
i made a mess
i forced dwight to resign prematurely
and i replaced him with andy
who loves this place so much he punched
a hole in it
it's a mess
in a hundred years who's gonna care
about big larry i don't care about him
right now is that right
that statue sucks
shut up shut your stupid pie holes just
laugh yeah cause you don't get it you're
not getting it okay a bunch of years ago
lawrence rutherford wrote and signed a
legally binding agreement with the
minnesota that's why this town exists
that's why all of you exist
okay lawrence rutherford is our
forefather he's our adam and eve our
tigris and euphrates and that statue
which sits on my family's land
commemorates all that he gave us and if
you don't get that well you're just an
ungrateful boob
you know what i'm changing my mind again
big larry's gonna stay right where he is
nope not gonna budge not only that but
i'm gonna double down on my efforts to
make sure each and every one of you
understands exactly how important he is
and why it's so important that he's
there and if you disagree you can burn
in hell
yeah just burn right up
you gotta go get your boy
okay no but i'm not done telling these
people why they're wrong and stupid okay
okay
pam i have another little project for
you does it have to do with these
shopping bags filled with hot dogs
or whip yes these are pre-cooked so it's
not absolutely necessary but i would
appreciate it if you could heat up 800
hot dogs for a little contest i'm going
to be having i would greatly appreciate
it when's the contest like um 10 minutes
how am i supposed to get a bunch
a good manager has got to be hungry
hungry for success okay who's hungry no
no no do not touch the food please not
yet that is our next event a hot dog
eating contest
for those of you who are curious the
world record is 54 and one half hot dogs
wow and you know what i personally have
cooked up enough so that each and every
one of you could break that record so
shoot for the stars okay
all right the team that eats the most
hot dogs in 10 minutes we'll be declared
the winner on your mark
get set can i have a turkey burger no
i have the only one i claimed it ready
turkey is a healthy meat yeah
please let's just okay it's very
important that you all try to eat as
many hot dogs as you can on your mark
get set
eat is there any mustard no mustard no
mustard just
eat it eat it phyllis dip it in the
water so it'll slide down your gullet
more easily
come on the winner gets a big big prize
i can't say you can't say or you can't
pronounce it the winner gets regional
managers salary for a year and a sebring
and the feeling that they are making a
difference in the world can we just take
those first two things the winner of
today gets my job
okay
i'm interviewing for a job at corporate
and they're only interviewing a handful
of people
and i'm the most qualified and i'll
probably get it all right
you're leaving i didn't want to tell
anybody i didn't want to cast a paul
over our fun beach day but you know what
i don't know who to recommend because
frankly nobody's stepping up
i am so hungry
do you expect me to believe that you're
truly making your recommendations on
this basis
word
there we go let's see it
i would rather work for an upturned
broom with a bucket for a head than work
for somebody else in this office besides
myself
game on come on four seconds come on
three
two
one stop you're eating
and the winner is andy bernard with 14
hot dogs
one came up 13 hot dogs everybody
oh
nobody told me we're gonna have hot dogs
what can i get you
uh not sure yet
breakfast lunch actually sorry i have a
question
i'm on kind of a quest to learn about my
family
the people on the wall are they
um
are they all deangelo's or top row is
below that is this thing we do the boot
challenge they say that when the first
deangelo came over from the old country
he was so hungry he ate three dinners
and one night so we make a large pizza
three pounds of spaghetti and meatballs
three pounds of chicken parm you eat it
an hour you're an honorary deangelo for
life and your meal's free and your
picture goes on the wall yeah but if you
don't it's a hundred bucks between you
and me it's kind of a messed up way to
trick people into doing like i'm gonna
do it oh
all right got ourselves a boot boy are
you sure about this sweetie i'm legally
required to ask you that at this point
tiffany it's the only thing in the world
i am sure about yeah buddy
[Music]
he's got two minutes to take that last
bite i think he's gonna do it
uh oh he's looking pretty sweaty
[Music]
[Applause]
my name
is nathan
collins brothers
[Applause]
you